غالبيه هذه السلع لم تعد في متناول
اللبنانيين
يقفون حائرين امام الاسعار بعد قرار
السلطات تسعير المواد الغذائيه بالدولار
وفق سعر صرف السوق السوداء
هذه
سرقه ونهب
ولكن
تتجاوز تامين الغذائي الى كل ما يفترض ان
يكون من بديهيه العيش موقفه بس على الاكل
والشرب طب ما في دواء في طبابه في اللي
عنده مريض اللي عنده دواء شو بيعمل
تتقلب اسعار السلع والخدمات من وقود
واتصالات وغيرهما وفق سعر الدولار فالسعر
الذي يسجله صباحا قد ينخفض خلال النهار
ليستعد صعوده مساء فيما تكمن المعضله في
عدم قدره مديريه حمايه المستهلك على ضمان
رقابه شامله على الاسعار ولهذا الواقع
الاقتصادي تبعات بنيويه على المجتمع
اللبناني
سنكون امام طبقه فاحشه الثراء وطبقه معدمه
وحين يختل التوازن بعدم وجود طبقه متوسطه
نكون امام انتاج صراع طبقي جديد كان ينعكس
ليس على مستوى الاقتصاد الاجتماعي المالي
فقط قد ينعكس ايضا على المستوى الامني
وهنا اتكلم عن الامان الاجتماعي
رقعه الدولره لتشمل مختلف القطعه في لبنان
وهو ما يعزز خشيه الخبراء من ارتفاع نسبه
التضخم وتعميق معاناه لبنانيين فالمماطله
في اعتماد حل اقتصادي شامل تطيل الازمات
وتجعل الاتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي
بعيدا
الاتفاق بيجي بيعمل بسد هيدي الفجوه
بالدولار وبالتالي بيعمل شيء استقرار بسعر
الصرف ولكن نحن بعدنا بعد عن هيدي اللحظه
الاسباب المعروفه اللي هي في خلافات
جوهريه حاول تنفيذ الشروط المسبقه للاتفاق
مع صندوق قصدي اقول انه قدامنا بعد مسار
من الالام والجلجله فيما خص التسعير وازاء
الدوله التي شبه الشامله في لبنان تم ثمن
يرى ان هذه الخطوه تتجاوز البعض النقدي
وتشكل انتقاصا للسياده الماليه للدوله
وقدرتها على التحكم في اقتصادها
باتت حياه اللبنانيين مضبوطه على تقلبات
سعر صرف الدولار فالمواطنون يرون في
القرارات الرسميه نوعا من الفوضى في ظل
غياب خطه شامله تعيد لهم حقوقهم في الغذاء
والتعليم والعلاج
الجزيره بيروت